Fill in the blank. Ban X.
Not books. Ban automatic assault rifles in schools
instead of critical race theory and intersectionality in schools.
Ban dehumanization. Ban fascism.
Ban racism. Ban anti blackness,
anti immigrant, anti woman.
Not books. Ban the erasure of history.
Not books. One of the most important things we can do right now
is really come to terms with our history in this country.
What is literally lodged on genocide,
it's lodged on fascism, whether it was indigenous,
whether it was African Americans
and what happened. We have to uproot that and be free of it
if we're gonna have a real future.
I don't spend a lot of time thinking about what to ban anything.
I'm just trying to see what I would love to create
and to create more space for,
rather than trying to police or dictate
who should or shouldn't be doing bad acts.
Formerly known as we're good.
We don't need it controlled by algorithms
which are controlled by a narcissistic multi billionaire.
I don't think we're gonna get anything good out of that rotten apple.
Ban keeping Black History Month only in February.
And talk about all histories all the time.
Not books. Ban corporate money and politics.
The federal election system is very deeply broken
as a result of a lot of factors,
including a Supreme Court case
that made it so that these corporations
can spend unlimited money in our elections
and subvert our democratic processes.
And so, yeah,
We gotta get money out of politics.
Ban the disconnection from the power of the word.
Because words are sacred. We are spell casting at every single moment.
I when we remember our intrinsic relationship with the earth,
we remember that the trees gave us everything we are now.
There are ancient elders. How dare we ban a book